[Music]
hey guys it's me Debbie
today we're covering the basics on soy
and why it's turning you into a
menopausal cancer plagued crazy lady and
I'm gonna set the record straight on one
you can keep sipping your soy latte in
peace ah my boy three years oh boy it's
gonna be a long day
ladies soy expanded soy sauce tofu
tempeh soy nuts soy milk needs Oh
textured vegetable protein you know like
that biggest [ __ ] vegans are devil
worshippers hey leave the pecans out of
this I'll take one for the team
let's go Abbi listen up first of all soy
is a terrible source of protein only
meat gives you what you need in order to
get jacked that's actually not true
soy is considered a complete protein
meaning it has all the amino acids our
body needs in order to function
optimally one cup of cooked soybeans
packs 22 grams of protein that's almost
as much of the steak so if you want to
switch things up if your meat every once
in a while you won't be missing out plus
some research suggests that soy actually
might help to lower cholesterol and
reduce your risk of heart disease so
it's totally healthy stuff soy stops
menopause anything that suppresses a
natural part of life cannot be good calm
down dubbing the controversy around soy
is that it contains isoflavones
isoflavones are plant-based compounds
called fight against that can interfere
with our endogenous
estrogen from binding its receptors so
the thinking is that if estrogen starts
to decline like it does during menopause
then maybe we can just boost her right
back up by eating some soy this is
actually being studied quite a bit one
large meta-analysis of 15 different
studies found that dietary isoflavones
help to reduce hot flashes without any
serious side effects another
meta-analysis of 62 studies in over
6,000 women found that phytoestrogens
helped to reduce hot flashes and vaginal
dryness but had no impact on night
sweats that all sounds pretty promising
but there's also a lot of other research
that has found no impact on menopause
symptoms when it comes to soy or phyto
estrogens the bottom line is it doesn't
seem like there's a clear-cut
standing of the impact of soy on
menopausal symptoms but we do know that
it's not a replacement for hormone
therapy so always speak to your doctor
about your treatment plan when you get
to that point your life eating soy
causes breast cancer soy nuts chill my
nan soon so this comes down to the fact
that yes breast cancer can grow in the
presence of excess estrogen and we know
that isoflavones and soy do act like
estrogen however there's no strong
research to suggest that soy causes
cancer so let's break it down in rat
research they have found that
isoflavones supplements may actually
promote tumor growth and in some small
experimental studies on humans they
found that soy protein increases the
number of epithelial cells in the
breasts and it's these epithelial cells
that are thought to be the most likely
to be cancerous the vast majority of
research on humans suggests that not
only a soy totally safe but may actually
be beneficial there's a lot of research
suggesting that there's no association
between soy and breast cancer and
actually there's some out there that
suggests that consuming soy am actually
reduce your risk of breast cancer or
prevent reoccurrence in those who had
breast cancer for example 36,000
postmenopausal women were studied and it
was found that those who consumed the
highest amounts of isoflavones from soy
products had a reduced risk of
postmenopausal breast cancer so while
there are a few inconsistencies in the
research the American Cancer Society
suggests that as long as soy is consumed
from food in moderation
so like three servings a day it's
totally safe to eat and drink now when
it comes to soy supplements these things
can become really easy to overdo so
currently in the American Cancer Society
recommends staying away from supplements
and sticking with food well my boyfriend
John David jr. wants to eat a tofu
burger and he grew a pair of boobs you
have a boyfriend anyways this is based
on the idea that again soy can act like
estrogen and estrogen is present
naturally in higher levels in women than
it is men so a lot of guys worry that
soy is going to interfere with our manly
hormones like testosterone but actually
things have found that even high level
consumption of soy does not cause the
moves in fact one meta-analysis found
that men who consumed soy had a lower
risk of prostate cancer so that tofu
burger actually might have some perks
well they're always made of GMOs so that
automatically heaps of bad news oh boy
I'd a bee that deserves a whole other
separate video to tackle but until then
I'll just say that there's lots of great
options out there there are non GMO and
organic and you can easily just identify
them in the marketplace using the
organic symbol great well until then I
will enjoy my extra cold coffee free soy
latte you mean soy milk you're drinking
soy milk obviously debbie has a lot on
her mind we have so much to talk about
so if you like this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up leave me a comment
below with some of your burning
nutrition questions subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen
[Music]